[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue sur le plateau des
chaînes parlementaires nous sommes
ensemble pour voir avec du recul
l'essentiel de la semaine politique et
parlementaire pour voir rien bonjour
katia est notre invité pour refaire
cette semaine politique et parlementaire
c'est jean-baptiste lemoyne
bonjour je vous remercie d'être avec
nous vous êtes sénateur de l'yonne et
vous êtes le seul parlementaire de
droite à avoir rallié emmanuel macron
pendant sa campagne
on va revenir avec vous sur toute
l'actualité de la semaine et dans
l'actualité françois bayrou qui a
présenté les grandes lignes de sa loi
pour moraliser la vie publique
une présentation qui intervenait en
pleine affaire ferrand cette semaine
également edouard philippe qui a reçu
les partenaires sociaux pour discuter de
la réforme du code du travail une
réforme qui passera pas voir des
ordonnances et puis enfin dernière ligne
droite pour la campagne des législatives
dont le premier tour aura lieu le 11
juin et on va commencer par
l'information de cette fin de semaine
donald trump qui retire son pays de
l'accord de paris sur les clés sur le
climat une décision coup de tonnerre
écoutez la réaction d' emmanuel macron
je prends note de la décision du
président américain de se désengager de
l'accord de paris sur le climat le
considère qu'il commet là une erreur
pour les intérêts de son pays et de son
peuple et une faute pour l'avenir de
notre planète nous ne négocierons pas un
accord moins ambitieux en aucun cas la
france ce soir appelle l'ensemble des
pays signataires à rester à la hauteur
des responsabilités qui sont les nôtres
et à ne rien aider america first et tant
pis pour la corde de paris a dit en
substance donald trump est ce qu'on peut
quand même le reprocher jean-baptiste
lemoyne au président américain
d'appliquer sa promesse de campagne
enfin moi je pense qu'on se bat c'est
que les états unis font le choix de se
retirer
finalement de la scène internationale
c'est valable sur le chantier climatique
c'est valable on l'a vu sur d'autres
chantiers type militaire stratégique
stratégie pour vous ça mais
mais ça veut dire que si les états unis
sont sur le départ de la scène
internationale je peux vous dire que la
france elle est sur le retour doit
verser à l'international parce que
regarder la façon dont le président de
la république désir soir dans une
attitude très solennelle a dit les
choses a tendu la main d'ailleurs un
certain nombre de forces vives
américaine qui semblaient travailler
pour lutter contre ces changements
climatiques et vous l'avez signalé une
intervention en france est naturellement
mais également une intervention en
anglais qui a été diffusé sur tous les
journaux télévisés américains
s'adressant finalement aux citoyens
américains en leur disant et avec quand
même ce magnifique détournement de la
phrase slogan de donald trump en disant
on va fait de fait la planète plus
grande ampleur donc honnêtement
là on a un président république dont on
voit bien que c'est la scène
internationale il est non seulement à la
hauteur des événements mais même tu
donne le tempo
on l'a vu précédemment avec le g7 à
taormina on l'a vu également au sommet
de l'otan on l'a vu justement pendant
cette période j'ai cette semaine de
temps il l'a vu donald trump qui s'est
longuement entretenu avec est ce que il
n'a quand même pas échoué à le
convaincre de ne pas sortir de cet
accord de paris vous savez vous pouvez
pas forcer quelqu'un à revenir
effectivement sur un certain nombre
d'engagements pris ou donc vous pouvez
lui poser les bases des enjeux lui
montrer qu'il fait fausse route
maintenant on voit bien que le processus
de décision de donald trump n'est pas
forcément à processus décision
rationnelle il est d'ailleurs lui même
très contesté dans cette décision y
compris au sein de son cabinet j'ai noté
donc vous savez je crois que emmanuel
macron en tant que président de la
république il a marqué les esprits lors
de ces sommets parce que on a bien vu
qu'il était voilà un des leaders
émergents d'aujourd'hui pour construire
le monde de demain alors on va revenir à
l'actualité parlementaire et politique
française avec d'abord ces soupçons
autour d'un ministre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
richard ferrand qui est dans la
tourmente depuis plus d'une semaine
après les révélations du canard enchaîné
sur une opération immobilière qui touche
sa compagne le parquet de brest a ouvert
une enquête préliminaire
jean-baptiste lemoyne question très
simple richard ferrand peut-il avec
intel tumulte rester au gouvernement
mais oui à ce stade oui bien sûr vous
savez le premier ministre l'a rappelé il
ya une jurisprudence qui existe depuis
des décennies en tout cas depuis des
années 90 qui est que effectivement à
ministres démissionnent lorsqu'il est
mise en examen on l'a vu deux années 90
on l'a vu dans les années 2000
aujourd'hui richard ferrand et il mise
en examen non une enquête a été ouverte
et il cette enquête dira s'il ya un
classement sans suite si au contraire il
ya des éléments qui permettent 2 est
donc aujourd'hui je crois que il faut
justement sortir de la posture purement
de de jeter l'anathème alors que la
justice ne s'est pas encore prononcée et
donc est le chef du gouvernement a été
très clair à ce stade il peut tout à
fait poursuivre sa mission très
différents par exemple de justement de
la sphère fillon parce que là il y avait
une mise en examen
et il y avait un candidat qui s'était
engagé à ne pas poursuivre sa
candidature s'il était mise en examen et
donc il y avait par jure donc les choses
sont très différentes et je crois qu'il
faut justement avoir en tête que la
majorité présidentielle ne déviera pas
de sa ligne de conduite qui est la mise
en oeuvre de cette loi
effectivement de moralisation de étaient
présents le fait qu'il ne démissionne
pas qu'ils se maintiennent est ce que ça
ne porte quand même pas préjudice aux
gouvernements et à emmanuel macron t on
chez moi je suis du terrain mais le
week-end dernier j'ai fait un certain
nombre de deux visites j'ai assisté à
des foires agricoles dans le département
de l'yonne
et bien je peux vous dire que on m'a
très très très très peu parlé de cela je
crois que ce qui intéresse les français
c'est se dire on est un tournant dans la
vie du pays
il ya un espoir c'est un espoir de de
faire bouger les lignes et donc c'est
avant tout cela qu'il regarde c'est cela
mais là aussi ce sondage qui est parue
ce jeudi 54% des français estiment qu'
on a tort de garder au gouvernement
richard ferrand oui il ya des pages rock
ça il ya des sondages paradoxaux puisque
j'en voyais un début de semaine qui
disait que en même temps c'est on aime
bien le en même temps en même temps il
ya environ 70% des français qui croient
dans la volonté réformatrice du
gouvernement pour modifier les règles
dans un sens justement de plus grande
clarté de plus grande moralisation de la
vie politique sur le scrutin
est-ce que ce que je vois c'est vous
voyez sondages et sondages montrent que
cela n'entache pas en tous les cas
l'élan réformateur qui dont est crédité
le gouvernement et le chef de l'île
manuel macron s'est affichée avec
richard ferrand il a déjeuné avec à
l'elysée il a dîné avec lui à vannes est
ce que dans cette affaire il ne se
comporte pas plus comme un ami que comme
un président de la république
non je crois que encore une fois vous
savez on est dans une attente aussi de
l'action politique où tout s'accélère la
vie médiatique s'accélère la vie
politique s'accélère mais en même temps
le présent république
il l'a toujours dit il souhaite être
aussi le maître des horloges et le
maître des horloges c'est pas être
balloté par l'actualité quotidienne tel
un bouchon sur la mer et donc
effectivement présent la république il
est là concentrer sur l'essentiel
le gouvernement est bien gouverne près
par les textes de loi à venir et le chef
du gouvernement edouard philippe a été
très clair sur les conditions dans
lesquelles un ministre pouvait rester ou
ne pas rester et pour l'instant est bien
différent remplit les conditions pour
mener son action gouvernementale
alors vous parlez ce projet de loi de
moralisation de la vie publique jeudi
après-midi françois bayrou le garde des
sceaux en a présenté les grandes lignes
de loi et une révision constitutionnelle
qui ont pour objectif de redonner
confiance dans l'action publique
flora sauvage armée du code de procédure
pénale le garde des sceaux a détaillé sa
réforme cet après midi devant la presse
mettre fin aux privilèges et aux
affaires qui gangrènent la vie politique
mais aussi favoriser l'indépendance du
parquet c'est l'ambition du projet de
loi de moralisation de la vie publique
pour redonner confiance dans notre vie
démocratique
ce que nous voulons c'est que les règles
soient les mêmes avec les garanties
nécessaires pour tous les citoyens
quelles que soient leurs rôles dans
notre vie démocratique et pour mettre
fin aux privilèges et aux régimes
d'exception
un projet de loi constitutionnelle
prévoit la suppression de la cour de
justice de la république et la fin du
droit pour les anciens présidents de la
république de siéger conseil
constitutionnel d'autres mesures
concernant les élus seront prises pas
plus de trois mandats identique
successifs interdiction des emplois
familiaux
les activités de conseil seront encadrés
la réserve parlementaire sera supprimé
et sera mise en place le remboursement
aurait elle des frais de mandat
il s'agit de mettre en place des
pratiques et des règles qui préserve les
citoyens des abus et leur grande
confiance dans la vie démocratique
enfin une refonte du mode de financement
de la vie publique va être mise en place
avec la création d'une banque de la
démocratie qui pourra accorder des prêts
aux partis politiques et aux candidats
autant de mesures qui nécessiteront la
convocation du congrès et la majorité
des trois cinquièmes des parlementaires
jean mathis lemoine est ce que présenter
ce projet de loi en pleine affaire
ferrand dont on vient de parler est ce
que c'est crédible mais c'est
extrêmement crédible pour une bonne et
simple raison c'est que mails macron il
a été élu par 66% des français et 25% au
premier tour sur la base de
ça un projet très concret et dans ce
projet il y avait une démocratie rénové
et donc mais c'était avant les affaires
qui donne au gouvernement
eh bien nous nous allons faire ce
pourquoi nous avons été élus et donc il
est normal aujourd'hui que le
gouvernement montre son attachement à ce
chantier parce que vous savez moi il ya
trois ans j'ai été élu au sénat en
indépendant parce que mon parti
politique estimait qu'il fallait
reconduire les sortants des sortants
d'ailleurs souvent pas exemplaire il se
trouve que j'ai battu dans le
département de l'yonne une personnalité
qui embauchait quelqu'un de sa famille
qui est sous le coup d'une mise en
examen qui cumule 124 années de mandat
comme l'a révélé l'ops embaucher
quelqu'un de sa famille ce n'était pas
interdite jusqu'à ce jusqu'à présent oui
dès lors qu'il ya effectivité d'un
travail accompli mais ce que je veux
dire c'est que ce sont des des moeurs
politiques que les français n'acceptent
plus et donc moi j'ai porté à l'époque
une candidature indépendante basée sur
la moralisation de la vie politique et
lorsque j'ai rejoint emmanuel macron le
15 mars dernier
je vais apporter ma profession de foi et
il a vu cet engagement il a compris du
coup pourquoi je le rejoignais et cette
ambition il la porte
elle se décline aujourd'hui avec le
l'avant projet de loi que porte françois
bayroux et je pense que véritablement ça
va donner un ballon d'oxygène à cette
vie politique française un peu sclérosé
ce que justement vous pensez que ce
projet de halle en tout cas ce nouvel
arsenal pour moraliser la vie politique
et publique va permettre d'éviter une
nouvelle affaire fillon une nouvelle
affaire ferrand comme on l'appelle vous
vous pensez que ça va assez loin
ah ben je trouve que ya un certain
nombre de curseur qui sont bien
positionnés ça éviterait une nouvelle
affaire thévenoud par exemple puisque
lille y aura l'obligation pour un
parlementaire de produire un quitus
fiscal montrer qu'on est à jour de ses
obligations déclaratives en matière de
fiscalité
puisque l'interdiction d'embaucher des
proches ascendant descendant au conjoint
sera posée effectivement ça éviterait et
bien par exemple l'emploi de madame
pénélope fillon
donc on voit bien que ça répond à un
certain nombre de deux problèmes qui ont
été posées d'attendre des français aussi
les bien sûr et d'attendre des français
est ce que ce n'est pas quand même un
texte qui renforce l'antiparlementarisme
je crois que l'ambition du prise en main
publique du
du chef du gouvernement c'est de
conforter l'action parlementaire mais
aussi de faire évoluer
comment dire les missions du parlement
mettre aussi l'accent sur l'évaluation
et le contrôle qu' il y ait plus de
moyens octroyés aux parlementaires dans
le cadre de ses missions là il y aura
moins de parlementaires mais avec
peut-être davantage de moyens pour
véritablement oui moi est-ce que ça
renforce pas quand même le fait de dire
que les élus sont des privilégiés
finances finalement non je crois que
l'image que ça renvoie
je crois qu'il ya l'objectif d'une
transparence et ça qui peut être contre
vous savez sur bien des chantiers les
choses ont progressé même depuis dix ans
en matière de réserve parlementaire
les projets sont rendus publics ça évite
je pense aussi peut-être que certains
parlementaires qui avaient tendance à
subventionner des associations dont il
se démène président voilà ce genre de
cannes n'existe plus maintenant il ya ce
projet de loi qui ce qui est déposé par
le gouvernement le parlement l'enrichira
d'ailleurs le gouvernement a dit qu' il
attendait que le parlement se positionne
sur les le non-cumul successifs pour les
maires parce que c'est vrai que les
maires des petites communes
eh bien parfois il n'y a pas forcément
énormément de vocation et donc on a
besoin peut-être pour eux de faire des
exceptions
alors va c'est au deuxième thème de la
semaine qui sera à l'ordre du jour de
l'assemblée bientôt le vaste chantier de
la réforme du droit du travail
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et cette semaine l'exécutif a donc
entamé des concertations pour engager la
refonte du code du travail le
gouvernement à son calendrier mais il ne
plaît pas forcément aux syndicats via
les lorrains avant même le contenu de la
réforme c'est le calendrier qui pose
problème
emmanuel macron souhaite faire voter dès
juillet une loi d'habilitation pour
légiférer par ordonnances ratification
finale avant le 21 septembre
un timing trop serré pour les syndicats
dont la cfdt a une nouvelle fois dit
qu'il lui fallait du temps de
concertation et que c'était pas pour
faire pour gagner du temps c'était pas
dilatoire mais il nous semble qu'il faut
il faut aller jusque les se laisser
jusqu'à fin septembre pour pour discuter
au contraire il y a urgence répond le
patronat c'est ce pari qu'il faut faire
ce pari des réformes rapidement le
rapidement dans cette concertation qui
est train de se passer pour que tout
soit taf un calendrier contesté car les
réformes envisagées sont importantes est
loin de faire consensus au premier plan
le plafonnement des indemnités
prud'homales en cas de licenciement
abusif
une mesure déjà présente dans la loi
travail mais qui n'a débouché que sur un
barème indicatif
face à l'impopularité de la mesure
aujourd'hui encore 56 % des français y
seraient opposés selon un sondage et lab
une ligne rouge pour la plupart des
syndicats de licenciement c'est pas un
produit de supermarché
ce il faut tenir compte de toutes les
situations nous avons contesté l'idée
qu'il pouvait y avoir un prix un
licenciement un prix unique un
licenciement
autres pistes de réforme la primauté de
l'accord d'entreprise sur l'accord de
branche
un référendum à l'initiative de
l'employeur pour valider un accord
d'entreprise minoritaire ou encore une
fusion des instances représentatives du
personnel
points de crispation majeur également un
moratoire sur l'application du conte
pénibilité il permet aux salariés du
privé confronté un travail difficile de
partir plus tôt à la retraite ou de
travailler à temps partiel
c'est une mesure de justice sociale pour
des gens qui meurent plus vite ou qu'ils
vieillissent plus mal parce que ils ont
eu des conditions de travail pénibles au
1er septembre prochain il faudra que
le dispositif si rien n'est fait soit
mise en place dans toutes les
entreprises
or il est plus que perfectible on sait
pas comment s'en sortir le premier
ministre edouard philippe fera pas
revenir la semaine prochaine lettre
d'orientation aux partenaires sociaux
pour cadrer les sujets des négociations
à venir
jean-baptiste lemoyne est ce que vous
pensez que le gouvernement prend un
risque en voulant légiférer par
ordonnances sur un sujet aussi aussi
sensible aussi complexe là encore une
fois personne n'est pris en traître lors
de la campagne présidentielle
emmanuel macron avait dit les choses il
les a tout le temps audi lors des débats
qu'il agirait de la sorte parce que en
matière d'emploi on ne peut pas se
satisfaire d'un pseudo modèle social
français qui se traduit par kwh à part
quand même un chômage massif même s'il
tend à décroître mais il ya quand même
cinq millions de personnes en france qui
soit n'ont pas d'emploi soit non pas un
emploi avec le nombre d'heures qui leur
convient et par ailleurs avec un marché
du travail qui est très segmenté c'est à
dire que selon que vous avez un bac +5
ou que vous êtes sans qualification eh
bien on voit bien qu'il ya d'énormes
différences et de difficultés à
s'insérer sur le marché du travail est
ce que vous comprenez que les syndicats
de non plus de temps pour l'un
concernant dit vous savez j'ai écouté
très attentivement dans votre reportage
laurent berger patron de la cfdt qu'est
ce qu'il dit il dit nous demandons à
avoir jusqu'à fin septembre
que dit edouard philippe le chef du
matin il dit il a dit fin septembre 1
dans l'autre portage et edouard philippe
le chef du gouvernement dit ça sera au
maximum au 21 septembre
écoutez si le désaccord il porte sur le
21 septembre
vous voyez que on n'est pas loin est ce
que veut dire ce qui compte c'est le
contenu
et ce qui est très intéressant c'est que
ça que j'étais rapporteur de la loi
travail au sénat et donc dans les
mesures qui sont proposés il ya
énormément de choses que nous avons voté
au sénat et que je retrouve dans cet
avant projet pour le moment le contenu
un edouard philippe emmanuel macron
n'ont pas donné de détails aux syndicats
pourquoi ce flou sur le contenu de ce
texte
non je crois que
les choses sont claires dans le projet
présidentiel et ça a été rappelé dans
votre reportage la volonté de pouvoir
graver dans le marbre un plancher et un
plafond prise indemnités plus de mal
donc contrairement à ce que dit
d'ailleurs monsieur martinez c'est pas
un prix unique de 1800 ciment c'est
pouvoir avoir des bornes hautes et
basses et donner de la visibilité à la
fois aux salariés à la fois l'employeur
lance là dessus ne lâchera pas dix
tunisiens rouge pour la transition
écoutez je pense que vous savez il ya
toujours des postures d'entrée de
négociation et puis il ya près comment
on en sort mais au-delà de ce sujet là
il ya également la volonté de donner
plus de cas de places à la corde
entreprises parce que c'est le bon sens
on trouve les meilleurs accords sur le
terrain avec des syndicalistes et des
employeurs qui connaissent la situation
de leur entreprise alors juste une
question quand même sur ce calendrier
les ordonnances à permet à un
gouvernement d'aller vite là où la
procédure normale prend plus de temps il
a prévu donc si on reprend le fin
septembre c'est quand même rapide ça
veut dire qu'en fait le parlement
assemblée et sénat examinerait et
voteraient tout ça très rapidement d'ici
à fin juillet vous pensez que ce
calendrier est réaliste
oui je pense savez ça se passe en en
plusieurs phases
la déclinaison de ces mesures d'une part
il ya la concertation qui est conduite
ensuite va être déposé un projet de loi
habilitant le gouvernement à légiférer
par ordonnance le parler ce projet de
loi d'habilitation qui sera discutée
devant les assemblées à partir de 20
dans la session ordinaire du mois de
juillet mais vous savez moi j'ai connu
de session ordinaire du mois de juillet
où parfois il y avait quatre gros textes
qui était discuté et donc je n'ai aucun
doute que y aura de la place pour le
travail en commission puis le travail en
séance publique à l'assemblée comme au
sénat senate sur quatre semaines
ordonnance à new york
vous savez le sait la majorité
sénatoriale elle a voté une loi travail
qui avait un peu plus d'ambition que
celle que prochain gouvernement
et il ya énormément d'amendements que
j'avais présenté avec mes collègues
gabouty et forissier et bien que je
retrouve dans le projet gouvernemental
et ses amendements bien du coup ils
pourront enfin voila vous en vigueur bon
c'est vrai c'était vraiment en place à
la troisième partie notre émission
consacrée aux élections législatives
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et on va voir comment se déroule la
campagne chez les républicains puisque
cette semaine françois baroin a sonné la
fin de la stratégie du ni ni qui était
en vigueur depuis 2011 explications de
vianney lorrain c'est une rupture avec
la stratégie établie il ya six ans une
réhabilitation du front républicain
portée par françois baroin chef de file
les républicains pour les législatives
son souhait si une victoire du fn est
possible au second tour dans une
triangulaire le candidat ps et l'air ou
la république en marche arrivé 3e devra
se désister j'exprime mon sentiment
personnel qui est une continuité d'un
engagement politique depuis 25 ans
contre le développement d'un front
national c'est madame l'hôtel ses loyers
dans le débat montre bien que c'est une
impasse il ya beaucoup de gens notamment
en milieu rural qui se retrouveront
autour de nos candidats pour être une
fois une fois de plus en temps des soins
une position saluée par plusieurs élus
qui souligne la nécessité du changement
on préfère un candidat démocrate à un
candidat l'extrême droite que les
républicains qui ont eu des hésitations
par le passé et cette position
aujourd'hui ça ne peut que me réjouir et
le ni ni n'a pas le même sens
aujourd'hui que celui qu'il pouvait
avoir il ya quelques mois le paysage
politique
objectivement a changé il faut que nous
aussi on soit capable de changer dans
nos réponses et l'intelligence de la
situation le ni ni ni front national ni
front républicain représente pourtant la
stratégie officielle des républicains
depuis 2011 mise en oeuvre lors des
dernières législatives en 2012 mais
aussi lors des départementales et
régionales en 2015 le positionnement
face au front national divise la droite
au lendemain du premier tour de la
présidentielle les élus aient l'air
s'opposent sur le soutien à apporter à
emmanuel macron jean françois copé l'un
des défenseurs du mini conteste
aujourd'hui la décision de françois
baroin je pense que c'est plus un peu
prématurée parce que c'est une question
très importante mais je voudrais être
sûr qu'elle va se poser le mieux est
donc d'attendre le soir du premier tour
un bureau politique tranchera le 12 juin
au lendemain du premier tour
la position officielle des républicains
est ce que vous comprenez gens
envahissent le moins de 7 ce changement
de stratégie cette décision de françois
baroin est ce que ça ne va pas accentuer
les fractures au sein du groupe
l ère du parti l air ça montre surtout
que l air c'est devenu une formation
politique un peu déboussolées sans cap
parce que ça commence une campagne
législative en voulant montrer les
biceps en 10 ans voit imposer une
cohabitation
et puis j'entends françois baroin il ya
quelques jours dire ah bah finalement on
participeraient bien aux bons projets de
loi et c'est donc ce que je vois c'est
que bien tout ça montre quoi qui a une
refondation une recomposition du paysage
politique qui est en marche
c'est le cas de le dire et on est un peu
comme en 58 ans fait avec le général de
gaulle qui rebat les cartes de la scène
politique française
et c'est très intéressant en 58 lui
nerfs parti nouvellement créée est
arrivé avec 200 députés à l'assemblée
nationale eh bien de la même façon je
peux vous dire que clairement les
candidats de la république en marche
refaire je pense une entrée massive ici
et il y aura une majorité
il y aura une majorité absolue pour
soutenir l'action du gouvernement
moi j'en suis convaincu parce qu'encore
une fois je me fie à mes déplacements
sur le terrain j'étais hier soir pour
soutenir nos trois candidats dans l'aube
gregory b sont moroses djamila haddad et
pascal lauréats et bien je peux vous
dire que j'ai vu des gens de droite qui
m'ont dit ben monsieur lemoine bravo
pour ce que vous avez fait parce que
nous aussi on est de droite et on a
envie que ça marche
et donc aujourd'hui on va soutenir le
candidat du président de la république
parce qu'il ya cette envie de ne pas
perdre cinq ans et puis de réussir voilà
alors nous on va continuer à parler en
ces législatives puisque nous
accueillons tristan kino maupoil du
figaro.fr c'est l'heure de la loupe du
scan
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour tristan c'est à vous vous avez
parlé de recomposition et ça se voit sur
les affiches de certains candidats
notamment dans les circonscriptions où
il n'y a pas de candidat investi par en
marche on voit sur les affiches majorité
présidentielle un peu partout certains
le revendique est-ce que ça va porter
préjudice à en marche cette confusion
qui est installée par certains candidats
je vois bien le phénomène auquel vous
faites allusion
certains montages photographiques
d'ailleurs ont été publiés dans la
presse et c'est parfois assez drôle de
voir des parlementaires effectivement
qui ont eu des mots parfois dure
vis-à-vis de macron aujourd'hui essayé
de se raccrocher aux branches d'une
majorité présidentielle bon je crois que
les électeurs vous savez ils sont
aujourd'hui très avisé y lisent et serra
et ce qui est important c'est que il est
d'abord la confiance qu'ils soient
donnés aux candidats de la république en
marche
et puis là où il n'y a pas de candidat
républican marche effectivement il ya
quelques circonscriptions dans lesquels
des personnalités ont indiqué qu'elle
soutiendrait l'action du gouvernement
quant à cauterets la confiance 8e
arrondissement il ya l'ancien ministre
du travail et des idées qui sont proches
sur ces réformes symboliques et puis il
ya votre ancien compagnon de route bien
une bonne dizaine qui est un ancien
juppéiste il faut soutenir les lequel
des deux noms mais d'ailleurs c'est très
intéressant
hier soir tous les deux l'un et l'autre
il était dans une même réunion publique
devant les marcheurs devant les
sympathisants les militants dans marche
pour se présenter présenter la façon
dont il voyait les choses et donc eh
bien ce sont les électeurs qui
trancheront mais ça peut semer le
trouble chez les lecteurs 22,7 ces deux
étiquettes
ça peut semer le trouble majorité
présentielle sais pas ce que vous et
bien après il y aura les électeurs
feront leur choix soit non ces
circonscriptions n'y a pas de candidat
en marche face à des ténors un soin de
droite ça est de gauche on comprend pas
bien comment s'est fait ce choix
pourquoi par exemple thierry solère qui
a appelé à travailler avec emmanuel
macron n'a pas de candidat de la
république en marche alors que nathalie
kosciusko morizet qui est signé l'appel
de thierry solère elle a un candidat non
mais les choses sont très différentes
entre l'un et l'autre
thierry solère il a été clair il a dit
moi je voterai la confiance au
gouvernement
je voterai le texte sur le travail
nathalie kosciusko-morizet la paix a été
au bout de la démarche est là non mais
la cygnet main tendue mais l'a pas dit
qu'elle voterait la confiance du
gouvernement
bon voilà je crois qu'il ya un moment il
faut savoir comme le dit même macron
prendre ce risque
il ya un moment faut pas essayer donc
soit on assume qu'effectivement on veut
participer à cette oeuvre de refondation
et on est clair et il n'y a pas à
tortiller ça c'est l'ancienne politique
qui veut essayer d'obtenir des gages je
te dis telle phrase est donc tutu
m'embête pas etc
non aujourd'hui il faut de la clarté et
vous n'envisagez oui ou non je soutiens
le gouvernement c'est ça la question
vous avez pris un risque justement il
vous n'avez pas été remerciés puisque
vous n'avez pas été nommé au
gouvernement malgré votre nom qui
circule est ce que vous n'avez pas été
déçu mais attendez ce qui compte c'est
pas la réussite personnelle c'est la
réussite du pays et le gouvernement y
tient énormément des premiers mails
macron gouvernement resserré avec
énormément de personnes qui est de la
société civile
moi j'ai en tête regardez monsieur blanc
caire à l'éducation nationale qui
connaît parfaitement le ministère et qui
on le voit est en train vraiment de
réussir sophie cluzel aux personnes
handicapées qui vient de ce monde
associatif du handicap
après écouter naturellement que si
lorsqu'on est appelé à participer à
cette équipe de france ça doit être
enthousiasmant mais il ya énormément de
mission à accomplir et je peux vous dire
que la ligue et l'estimé mutuelles
qu'elles existent entreprises ont leur
public et moi et bien attendez c'est pas
le sujet le sujet certains étaient 90
doivent rentrer
christophe castaner l'a dit ça doit être
quel profil des ralliés de la dernière
minute ou ceux qui étaient là depuis le
début
non honnêtement moi je compose pas le
gouvernement cette présence d'un public
et le pré ministre ce qui compte c'est
que on va avoir une photo de la majorité
le 18 juin
il faut ensuite que cette majorité est
bien elle se retrouve pleinement
effectivement dans l'exercice des
fonctions exécutives
mais encore une fois vous savez il ya le
gouvernement il ya le parlement qui va
être revalorisée par rapport à toutes
ces missions d'évaluation et de contrôle
et puis il ya également le mouvement de
la république en marche qui est une
structure importante il faut continuer à
faire vivre cet élan démocratique aidé
beaucoup de français qui ne se
reconnaissaient pas dans les familles
traditionnelles sont venus à en marge et
donc
voilà vie ce qui est pour certains vivre
justement cette structure il faut au
scénario vous êtes sénateur créer un
groupe mais crown istres alors l'élu je
pense qu'il faut qu'ils aient un
carrefour d'une façon ou d'une autre qui
permettent aux maquereaux nist issus des
différentes familles des différents
groupes parlementaires de se retrouver
un carrefour
ça peut être une un lien plus ou moins
souple est-ce qu'il s'agit d'un
intergroupe est ce qu'il s'agit d'un
groupe
les choses ne sont pas encore tranchées
à ce stade vous discuté mais ce sont des
débats qu'on peut avoir avec françois
patriat avec jacques mézard l'ancien
président du rds c'est quand ça ne
l'était mais avec ça va pas jusque là
non c'est très informel déjà vous savez
le sénat il est en phase de
renouvellement
donc on aura les idées plus claires je
pense aux 30 au 30 septembre
et c'est là que les choses pourront se
formaliser eh bien merci beaucoup jean
baptiste lemoyne avoir été l'invité de
parle-moi de dos merci katia et à la
semaine prochaine
[Musique]